and a new effort by president trump to
boost his campaign using a familiar
tactic
the president yesterday helped resurrect
a false conspiracy theory
he used to challenge barack obama's
right to be president this time
to attack kamala harris mr trump refused
to reject
a bogus claim about her citizenship
circulating online
that the senator doesn't qualify to be
joe biden's running mate
as ed o'keefe reports his comments
prompted immediate pushback from the
biden
campaign i just heard that i heard it
today that she doesn't meet the
requirements
instead of stopping the racist attack
against senator kamala harris the
president amplified it when asked if he
thought
she was eligible to run for vice
president i would have assumed the
democrats would have checked that out
before she gets chosen to run for vice
president
harris's parents immigrated from jamaica
and india she was born in oakland
california
and any person born in the united states
is an american citizen
so there's no doubt about harris's
eligibility the attack mirrors the
racist accusations mr trump once made
against former president barack obama
why doesn't he show his birth
certificate
harris's sister maya responded on
twitter writing there are no gradations
of birtherism
you're either in or you're out earlier
in the day the president had leveled a
sexist attack on the senator
now you have a sort of a mad woman i i
call
her because she was so angry and so such
hatred
with justice kavanaugh the biden harris
campaign denounced the president calling
his attacks unsurprising
and said he makes a fool of himself by
distracting from the pandemic
joe biden and harris are wasting no time
showing how they would govern
they spent most of thursday holding
briefings on the pandemic with experts
and biden is now calling for a
nationwide mass mandate to fight the
coronavirus
the governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing be a patriot
protect your fellow citizens
protect your fellow citizens step up
do the right thing harris said voters
should be asking the trump
administration
a key question when am i actually going
to get
vaccinated because there may be some
grand gestures offered by the current
president
about a vaccine but it really doesn't
matter
until you can answer the question when
am i going to get vaccinated
the president dismissed those criticisms
saying that biden is trying to
politicize the pandemic but of course
the president said that and attacked
harris
in a political way during a government
briefing on the coronavirus
by the way we now know that biden and
harris will
address the virtual democratic
convention next week from a downtown
event center
in biden's hometown of wilmington
delaware the two are set to make yet
another appearance together
today michelle a lot of news next
weekend and you'll be there thank you so